[Applause]
thank you thank you very much thank you
my fake study audience
love to see you all in your smiling
faces uh what can i say it's august
and i'm still here at home uh i haven't
spent this much time in my yard since i
used to have to grow my own weed
i uh oh i missed my old life i got to
tell you this time of year i used to
always be like in the midwest
doing stand-up gigs on the weekends and
god i missed it today i called up the
westboro baptist church and i asked if
they would
come over and pick at my house
but hey let's look on the bright side
we've got a great show
we've got chris evans is on captain
america and we're going to be talking
about our president
the incredible sulk
oh yeah he had quite a week uh trump he
uh some disastrous interviews they asked
him about the
high death tolls from cobit he said it
is what it is
ah yes thanks president shrug emoji
i'm uh i'm sure that looked better when
melania wrote it on the jacket
yeah he said uh you know his usual
litany of crazy things is that the
coronavirus
will go away like all things go away
says the man who will not go away
i i i'm starting to think something
if someone was paid to take his dementia
test
[Laughter]
and he has been hammering away on joe
biden's age
i love this don't vote for this really
ancient guy who's
three years older than me
democrats keep grumbling that biden
needs to be more visible
no no he needs to be more invisible
don't [ __ ] this up this is working
this [ __ ] is working they announced this
week biden will
not go to milwaukee at the democratic
convention
where there is none he will accept the
nomination from home in delaware he will
become
the first official candidate to accept
the nomination of a webcam
and very likely may be the first to
accept it without pants on
good keep him safe keep the idea of joe
biden that's what we really like
let him you know do that thing where he
does and
watch from home he says he's going to be
watching from home on the
state-of-the-art 13-inch crt
color television he takes such pride in
but uh yeah it's going to be an
interesting night when he accepts the
nomination his wife jill is going to get
up on a ladder and drop a balloon
but i tell you the writing is on the
wall here that uh biden i think is going
to win the election
and so the republicans are just going to
now steal everything that they possibly
can listen to this
this week kodak kodak you know the
picture people okay
we're awarded a 765 million dollar loan
to begin producing drug ingredients
like i always say you're never told to
start experimenting with drugs
and finally trump says he has done more
for the black community than anyone
since
lincoln yes that's so true because
there's so much love in the black
community for donald trump for months
they've been marching in the streets
chanting his name